the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
ok so this is an important day and
Friday was an important day I I hope you
enjoyed professor's Fras terrific
lecture as much as I did you probably
saw me taking notes like mad for the
section that's now to be written about
stochastic gradient descent so and he he
promised a theorem if you remember and
there wasn't time and so he was going to
send it to me or still is going to send
it to me I'll report I haven't got it
yet so I'll but I'll bring it to class
wait and see hopefully about and that'll
give us a chance to review stochastic
gradient descent the central algorithm
of deep learning and then this today is
about the central structure of deep
neural nets and some of you will know
already what they how they're connected
what what the what the function f the
learning function it could call it the
learning function that that's
constructed the whole system is aiming
at constructing this function f which
learns the training data and then
applying it to the test data and the
miracle is that it does so well in in
practice that's what has transformed
deep learning into such a important
application so so so this is
this though Chapter seven has been up
for months on the mascot mit.edu slash
learning from data sight and I'll add it
to stellar because that's where you'll
be looking for it okay and then the
second the backpropagation the way to
compute the gradient I'll probably
reached that idea today and you'll see
what it's the chain rule but how is it
organized okay so so what's the
structure what's the plan for deep
neural nets good start starting here so
what we have is training data so we have
vectors x1 to X what should I use for
the number of training of samples that
we have in the training the training
data well Sadie for data ok and each
vector those are called feature vectors
so equals feature vectors so each one
each X is uh has like m features so
maybe it maybe I my notation isms isn't
so hot here I have a whole lot of
vectors let me not use the subscript for
those right away so vectors feature
vectors and each vector has got maybe so
we say m features like if we were
measuring height and age and weight and
so on those would be features so the job
is of the the job of the neural network
is to create a and
and we're going to classify maybe we're
going to classify men and women or boys
and girls
so our let's make it a classification
problem a just a binary so the
classification problem is what should we
say minus one or one which is sort of or
zero or one or boy or girl or cat or dog
or truck or car or anyway just two
classes to two class so I'm just gonna
do two class classification so the we
know which class the training data is in
for each vector X we know the right
answer so we want to create a function
that gives the right answer and then
we'll use that function on other data
people know so let me write that down
create a function f of X that so that
that gets most of gets the class correct
in other words f of X should be negative
for when when the classification is
minus 1 and f of X should be positive
when the classification is plus 1 and as
we know we don't necessarily have to get
every X every sample right that may be
overfitting if there's some sample
that's just truly weird by getting that
right we're going to be looking for
truly weird data in the test set and and
that's not a good idea we want we want
the rule that we're trying to discover
the rule the
covers almost all cases but not every
crazy weird case okay so that's our job
to create a function f of X that is
correct on almost all of the training
data yeah
so before I draw the picture of the
network let me just remember remember to
mention the site playground I don't know
if you've looked at that so I'm gonna
ask you playground at tensorflow dot org
how many know that site or have messed
with it just just a few okay okay so
it's not a very sophisticated site it's
got only four examples for examples and
and the yeah so the so one example is a
whole lot of points there are blue B for
blue inside a bunch of points that are
another set that are old for orange
orange but okay so those are the two
classes orange and blue so the points X
and the the feature vector is is the
feature vector is here is just the X
what the coordinates features are the X
Y coordinates of the point and our job
is to find a function that's positive on
these points and negative on those
points so there's a simple model problem
and
I recommend well just partly it's if
you're a expert in deep learning this is
for children but but morally here I
certainly learned from playing in this
playground so you you set the you you
set the step size do you set it or does
it say no yeah yeah I guess you can
change it I haven't I don't think I've
changed it what else do you said oh you
you set the the nonlinear activation the
nonlinear activation function active
I'll say function and let me just go
over here and say what functions people
now mostly use the the activation
function is called riilu pronounced
different ways I don't know how we got
into that crazy thing for this function
that is zero and X so the function riilu
as a function of X is the maximum the
larger of 0 and X so it produces the
point is it's not linear and the point
is that if we didn't allow non-linearity
in here somewhere
we couldn't even solve this playground
problem because if our classifiers were
all linear classifiers like support
vector machines I couldn't separate the
blue from the orange with a plane I it's
got to somehow create some nonlinear
function which is maybe the function is
trying to be a good a good function
would be a function of r and theta maybe
maybe r minus 5 so maybe the distance
out to the that let's suppose that
distance is 5 then r minus 5 will be
negative on the Blues because R is small
and our minus 5 will be positive on the
oranges because R is bigger and
therefore we will have the right signs
less than 0 greater than 0 and it'll
classify this the this data this
training data yeah so so it has to do
that this is not a hard one to do there
are four examples as I say two are
trivial it solves it finds a good
function well yeah I've forgotten
they're so trivial they've they don't
shouldn't be mentioned and then this is
the medium test and then the hard test
is when you have oranges you have a sort
of spiral of oranges and inside you have
a spiral of blue satin that was a cooked
up by a feed so you would so that the
system is trying to find a function
that's positive on one spiral and
negative on the other spiral and that
takes quite a bit of time many many
epochs I learned what an epoch is did
you know what an epoch is I I didn't
know whether it was just a fancy word
for counting the steps in gradient
descent but it counts it counts the
steps all right but one epoch is the
number of steps that matches the size of
the training data so if you have a
million samples we're grading ordinary
gradient descent you would be doing a
million you have a million by
in problem per step of course stochastic
gradient descent just does a mini batch
of 1 or 32 or something but anyway if we
had yeah so so it's the number of you
have to do enough mini batches so that
the total number you've covered is the
equivalent of one full run through the
training data and that was interesting
point did you pick up that point that in
stochastic gradient descent you could
either do it you could either do a mini
batch and then put them back in the soup
so with replacement or you could just
put your data in some order from wonder
zillion so here's here's of a first X
and then more more X's and then just and
randomize the order so you'd have to
randomize the order for for stochastic
gradient descent to be reasonable and
then take a mini batch and the mini
batch in a mini batch in a mini batch
and when you get to the bottom you've
finished one epoch and then you'd
probably randomize again maybe if you
were if you were doing it if you wanted
to live right and go through the mini
batches again and probably do a thousand
times yeah anyway so I haven't said yet
what you do what this f of X is like but
you can sort of see it on the screen
because as it creates this function f it
kind of plots it and what you see on the
screen is the is the zero set for that
function so it perfect would be for it
to go through zero if I had another
color oh I do have another
look this is the first time the whole
semester blue has appeared okay so so if
it if the function was positive there in
the in this part on the Blues and
negative outside that region for the
oranges that would be just what we want
right
that would be what this little
playground site is creating and on the
screen you'll see it you'll see this
this curve where it crosses zero so that
curve where it crosses zero is supposed
to separate the two sets one set is
positive one set is negative where it's
zero is in between and the point is it's
not a straight line because we've got
this nonlinear function this this this
is nonlinear and it allows us to to have
functions like our minus five and so at
at five that's where the function would
be zero and that you'll see that on the
screen you might just go to tents or
playground at tensorflow of course
tensorflow is a big big system this is
the their child's department but it's I
thought it was pretty good and then on
this site you you decide how many layers
there will be how many neurons in each
layer so you create the structure that
I'm about to draw and and you won't be
able to get to solve this two problem to
find a function f that learns that data
without a number of layers and a number
of neurons if you don't give it enough
you'll see it struggling but it won't it
just it's creating that the the zero set
tries to follow this but it but it has
it gives up at some point
this one doesn't take too many layers
and the two trivial examples just are
just a few neurons do the job okay so
now so that's a little comment on on one
website if others father if you know
other websites that I should know and
should call attention to could you send
me an email I you know I'm just not
aware of everything but out there or if
you know a good a good convolutional
neural net CNN that is available to
practice on where you could give it the
training set that's what I'm talking
about here I'd be glad to know because I
I just don't know all that
that I should okay so what does the
function look like well as I say linear
isn't going to do it but linear is a
very important part of it of the of this
function f so the function f really has
the form well so we've got we start here
with a vector of one two three four M is
five this is the this is the vector X
five components okay so let me erase
that now okay
so then we have layer one with some
number of points let's say N one is six
neurons let me make this simple I'll
just have that one layer and then I'll
have the output this will be the output
layer
and it's just gonna be one number so
each of these so I'm gonna have a matrix
a one that takes me from this a one will
be this will be 5 by no six by five
because I want six outputs and five
inputs six by five matrix so I have 30
weights to choose there and so the the
the y that comes out is gonna be y 1
will be a 1 times X 0 so X 0 is the is
the feature vector with five components
so it's so that's a purely linear thing
but we also want a an offset function
offset vector so that's a vector this is
then this is that was a y that's coming
out has six components the a one is six
by five the X naught was five by one and
then of course this is six by one so
these are the these are the weights well
these are these yeah I'll call them all
weight weights to compute so in this so
these are connected usual picture is to
show these all these connections I'll
just put in some of them so in here we
have thirty plus six parameters
thirty-six parameters and then I'm going
to close this it's gonna be a very
shallow thing so that will be just just
one by six yeah just okay
right so we're just getting one output
so it's that's just a vector at this
final point but of course the the whole
idea of deep neural Nets is that you
have many layers so you have that 36
more realistically as in the tens of
thousands and you have it multiple times
and the idea seems to be that the first
layer that you can sort of separate what
layer one learns about the data and from
what layer two learns about the data
layer one there's a one apparently by
just looking after the computation this
learned some some basic facts about the
data this learns the next next a to
which would go in here would learn more
detail and then a three would learn more
details so we would have a number of
layers and it's that construction that
has made neural net successful but I
haven't finished because right now it's
only linear right now I just have
alcohol at a two in here right now I
would just have a matrix multiplication
apply a 1 and then apply a 2 but in
between there's a is a one by one action
on each by this function
so that function acts on that number to
give that number back again or to give
zero so in in there in there is real ooh
right in there in this it becomes real
ooh on each six six copies of reacting
on each of those six numbers right
so that really x1 comes from y1 by
applying riilu to it then that gives the
X so here are the Y's from the linear
part and here are the X that's why ones
that's a vector y1 the linear from just
a linear plus an affine map linear plus
constant
that's a fine and then the next step is
component by component we apply this
function and we get X - X what yeah and
then do it again and again and again so
do you see that the function how do i
describe now the function f of x so the
learning function which depends on the
on the weights on the a's and b's is so
I start with an X I apply F 1 a 1 to it
yeah let me do this so what what this is
the function f of X f of X is going to
be F 3 let's say of F 2 of F 1 of X 1 2
3 parentheses right okay so it's a chain
you could say F is a what's the right
word for a chain of functions if I take
a function of a function which is the
reason I use the word chain
the chain rule gives the derivative so a
function of a function of a function
that's called composition composing
function so this is a composition I
don't know if there's a standard symbol
for starting with F 1 and do some
composition and do some composition and
now what what are those separate F those
separate FS are the or the so the
separate FS are the F 1 of a vector
would be in tunes the real part the
nonlinear part of a 1 X 0 plus B 1 so 2
parts you do the linear or affine map on
your feature vector and then you
component by component you apply that
nonlinear function and it took some
years before that nonlinear function
became a big favorite people imagine
that it was better it was important to
have a smooth function so the original
functions were sigmoids
like s curves but but of course it
turned out that experiment showed that
this worked even better yes so that
would be F 1 and then F 2 would have the
same form and F 3 would have the same
form so maybe this had 36 weights and
the next one would have another number
and the next another number so we're
getting you get quite complicated
functions by composition by you know
like e to the sine of X or e to the sine
of the logarithm of X or things like
that
pure masses asked could you get what
functions can you get you know try to
think of them all now what kind of
functions do we have here what can I say
about f of X as a function as a math
person what what kind of a function is
it so it's created out of matrices and
vectors out of a linear or affine map
followed by a nonlinear by that
particular nonlinear function so what
kind of a function is it well I've
written though with those words down up
here at f of X is going to be a
continuous piecewise linear function
because every step is continuous that's
a continuous function linear functions
are continuous function so we certainly
have we're taking a composition of
continuous function so it's continuous
and it's piecewise linear because part
of it is linear and part of it is
piecewise linear so so this is some
continuous piecewise linear function
function from from of X X and M
dimensions okay
so one one little math question which I
think helps to understand to Mike like
to swallow the idea of a chain of of the
kind of chain we have here of linear
followed by riilu so so here's my
question this is a question I'm going to
ask
and by the way back propagation is
certainly going to come when Z rather
than today that's a major topic in
itself so let me keep going with this
function could you get any function
whatsoever this way well no you only get
continuous piecewise linear functions
that's a it's an interesting case let me
just ask you well one of the exercises
says if if I took two continuous
piecewise linear functions do you have a
the next 20 minutes are an attempt to
give us a picture of the graph of a
piecewise linear function so what what
say in say a function of two variables
so I have M equal to two and I draw its
graph okay help me to draw its graph so
this would be a graph of f of x1 x2 and
it's going to be continuous and
piecewise linear so what does its graph
look like that's that's the question
what's the graph of a piecewise then
your function looks like well it's got
flat pieces right in between the change
from a Medusa piecewise that means it's
got different pieces but within a piece
it's linear and the pieces fit next to
fit with each other because it's
continuous so I visually
is that the well it's like origami this
is the theory of origami almost so right
origami you take a flat thing and you
fold it along straight folds so so
what's different from origami maybe not
much
well maybe origami allows more than we
allow here origami would allow you to
fold it up and over so origami would
give you a multivalued thing because you
know it's got a top and a bottom and
other folds this is just going out to
infinity in flat pieces and the question
will be how many pieces so let me ask
you that question how many pieces do I
have you see what I mean by a piece so
so I'm thinking of a graph that has
these flat pieces and they're connected
along straight straight edges and those
straight edges come from from the real
ooh operation that well that's got two
pieces actually we could do in one day
and one day we could count the number of
pieces pretty easily so what would what
would be a piecewise linear let me put
it over here on this side and erase it -
okay
so here's a maple one a continuous
piecewise linear
f I'll just draw its graph so okay so
it's got straight pieces straight pieces
like so yeah you've got the idea it's a
broken line type sometimes people say
broken line but that I'm never sure
that's a good description of this
piecewise linear continuous so it's
continuous because the pieces meet and
it's piecewise linear obviously okay so
that's the kind of picture I have for a
function of one variable now that my
question is as an aid to try to
visualize this function in 2d is to see
if we can count the pieces see if we can
count the pieces yes and that for that
so that's in this notes I found it in a
paper by five authors for a from for a
meeting and so actually the whole world
of neural nets it's it's the conferences
every couple of years that that
everybody prepares for submits more than
one paper so it's kind of a piecewise
linear conference and those are the the
big conferences okay so this is the back
propagation section and I want to look
at this at the okay so I'm gonna show
this paper by Kleinberg and for others
Kleinberg is a he's a computer science
guide Cornell he was a PhD from here in
math and he's a very
and significant person on not on not so
much on neural networks as just the
whole this whole part of computer
science right so anyway they and other
people to have have asked this same
problem suppose you have suppose I'm in
two variables and suppose so what are
you imagining now for the surface of the
graph of this of f of X and why it has
these it has these lines fold lines
right I'm thinking it has fold lines so
I start could start with a complete
plane and I fold it along along one line
so now it's like Ray Lu is one play half
plane they're going to a different half
plane there everybody with it and now I
take that function that surface which
just has two parts and I put in another
fold
okay how many parts have I got now I
think four am i right four parts yes
because this will be different from this
because it was folded along that line so
these will be four different pieces they
they have the same value at the center
there and this and they match along the
lines but there's so the number of flat
pieces is four for this so that's with
two folds and now I just want to ask you
with M folds how many pieces are there
can I get up to three folds so I'm gonna
look for the number of folds so let me
let me just use a get a notation maybe R
R is the number of number of flat pieces
and M is the dimension of X in my
picture it's 2 and n is the number of
folds so let me say it again
I'm taking a plane I'll fold it plane
because the dimension was 2
I'll fold it fold it n times how many
pieces
how many flat pieces so this would be
this would be a central step in
understanding how close their function
you know what freedom you have in the
function f for example can you
approximate any continuous function by
one of these functions f by taking
enough folds seems like the answer
should be yes and it is yes so that's
the that's one big for pure math that's
one question is the is this class of
functions universal so the universality
theorem would be to say that any any
function sine X whatever could be
approximated as close as you like by one
of these guys with enough fold and over
here we're kind of making it more
numerical we're going to count the
number of pieces to just to see how
quickly do they grow so what happens
here so I have four folds now this right
now I have n equal to I mm is two here
in this in this picture
and I'm trying to draw the surface and
here I've put in two did I take in yeah
two folds and now I'm gonna go up to
three folds okay so let me fold it along
that line how many pieces have I got now
let's see can I count those pieces is it
seven so what is a formula what if I do
another fold what happens what end we do
another folder yeah yeah maybe that's
gonna be it it's a kind of nice question
because it is care to visualize this
thing okay so what happened how many how
many of those lines will be if I put in
a fourth line how many yeah how many new
folds do I create that's kind of the
question and I'm assuming that fourth
line doesn't go through any of these
points it's sort of in general position
yeah so I put in a fourth line done it
there it is okay so what happened here
how many new ones did it create how many
new ones did it create let me make that
one green because I'm distinguishing
that's the guy that's added after the
original we had we had seven we had
seven pieces and now we now we've got
more was it seven it was wasn't it one
two three four five six seven but now
how many pieces have I got or how many
how many pieces that did this did this
new line create that's what we want to
build it up use a recursion
how many pieces did this new new
well this new line folded created one
new piece there right one new piece
there one new piece there one new piece
there so there are four new pieces okay
yes so there's some formula right that's
gonna tell us that and now what would
the next one create well I've got now I
have one two three four lines so now I'm
gonna put through a fifth line and that
will create a whole bunch of pieces I'm
losing that losing the thread of this
argument but you're onto it right yeah
so any any suggestions yeah okay yes
there that's right so there's a
recursion formula that I want to know
and I learned it from Kleinberg paper
and then and then we have an addition to
do so the recursion will tell me how
much it goes up each with each new
function and then we have to add okay so
the recursion formula let me write that
down
so this is our of and and M now I'd like
to find a formula for it's the number of
flat pieces in M with an M dimensional
surface well we're taking em to be two
and n folds and let's just so an equal 1
2 3 let's let's write down the what the
numbers we know with with one fold how
many pieces too good so far so good with
one fold there were two pieces so this
is the count R and then with two folds
how many we've gone past that point so
can we get back
to just those two was it for okay thanks
now when I put in that third fold how
many did I have without the green line
yet seven was it seven and when the
fourth window went in that green went
how many have I got in this picture so
the question is how many new ones did I
create I guess so that that that line
got chopped into that piece that piece
that piece that piece four pieces for
the new line four pieces for the new
line and then each of those pieces like
added added a flat bit because it that
piece from here to here separated these
two which were previously just one piece
one flat piece they followed it on that
line I folded on this I folded there I
think it went up by four to eleven so
now we just have to guess a formula that
gives those matches those numbers and
then of course we really should guess it
for any M and any N and I'll write down
the formula that they found it's it
involves binomial numbers every
everything in the world involves
binomial numbers because they satisfy
every identity you could think of
so here's their formula R of with
enfolds and we're in M dimensions so we
believe early and our thinking had m
equal to 2 but we should you know grow
up and get em to be 5 dimensional so we
have a 5 dimensional let's not think
about that ok so so it turns out it's
binomial numbers and 0 & 1 up 2 and M so
so for m equal to 2 which is my picture
it's ends and 0 plus N 1 plus n 2 and
and and what are these what is that into
mean for example what's that that's a
binomial number I don't know if you're
keen on binomial numbers some people
their whole lives go into binomial
numbers so so it's something like is it
is it n factorial divided by n minus 2
factorial + 2 factorial I think that's
what that number means that's the
binomial number so this would be I go up
to so at this point I'm hoping to get
the answer 7 I think right now I've put
in I've gone up to am equal to I mean
Emmy put that I've gone up to - so I've
yeah so I think yeah I've obviously
allowed for 3 3 cuts and they are when
we had just 3 was 7 so is that
is this so so this is now I'm taking em
to b3 and I'm hoping for hope answer is
seven so what is 3 what is 3 so I add
these 3 things so what is 3 the binomial
number 3 with 2 forgotten how to say
that I'm ashamed to admit 3 choose 2
thanks
I knew there was a good way so what is 3
choose 2 well put it in 3 and 2 it's in
there already
so it would be 6 over 1 times 2 this
would be 3 would that be 3 and what is 3
choose 1 how do you know that you
probably right mm-hm
3 I think yeah oh yeah probably a
theorem that that if these add to 3
yeah so so this I'm doing N equals 3
okay so we yeah I agree that's 3 and
what about n to 0
what's that you have to live with 0
factorial by 0 factorial is by no means
0 what so what is 0 factorial 1 yeah I
remember when I was an undergraduate
having a bet or math I won but he didn't
pay off so yeah so so 3 this is 3
factorial over 3 factorial times zero
fighters so it's 6 over 6 times 1 so
isn't one yeah so 1 in 3 and 3 makes 7
so it proves their formula
well done quite proved the formula but
their way to prove it is by an induction
and I'll just if you like this this
stuff the
the recursion that you use induction on
which is just what we did now what we
did here here comes in at number four
and it cuts through oh yeah and then we
just counted the the four pieces there
so yeah so they let me just tell you
what they are of N and M the number
we're looking for is the number that we
had with one less cut so that's the
previous count of flat pieces plus the
number of the plus the number that was
here was for the number of pieces that
cut that and that's our of n minus 1 M
minus 1 yeah and yeah I won't go go
further times up but this the and that
rule for recursion is proved in the in
the section 7.1 taken from the paper by
Kleinberg and others yeah so ok I think
this is I don't know what you feel this
for me this like gave me a better
feeling that I was understanding what
kind of functions we had here and so
then the question is to with this family
of functions we want to choose two we
want to choose the A's and the weights
the A's and the B's to give to to match
the training data and so that we have a
problem in in minimizing the total loss
and we have a we have a gradient descent
problem so we have to find the gradient
so that's Wednesdays job Wednesdays job
is to find the gradient of F
okay and that's backpropagation good
thank you very much that's that's 7.1 is
done